[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله معكم ليلى الشيخ
ليث وفي العناوين
في رقم الانقاذ تواصلوا البحث عن
المفقودين جراء الليبيه السلطات تعلن تضرر
نحو 70% من البنيه التحتيه وانهيار 11
جسرا منها خمسه تربط المدن المنكوبه شرقيه
ليبيا ومخاوف امميه من خطر تفشي الامراض
بسبب المياه الملوثه
وفي المغرب استمرار جهود اغاثه المنكوبين
من زلزال الحوز استئناف الدراسه في
المناطق المتضرره تدريجيا بدءا من اليوم
وبدء حصر للمنازل المنهاره لدعم اصحابها
ماليه
صفقه تبادل سجناء بين ايران والولايات
المتحده ببساطه قطريه خمسه امريكيين
وافراد اسرهم يصلون الدوحه
وايرانيان يصلان طهران قادمين من الدوحه
بعد اخراج الولايات المتحده عنهما رئيس
الوزراء القطري يقول ان بلاده تامل ان
يمهد الاتفاق لمزيد من التفاهمات وبايدن
يثمن
[موسيقى]
البدايه من تداعيات السيول في شرق ليبيا
الموضوع
[موسيقى]
تتواصل جهود اجهزه الاسعاف الليبيه
بمسانده فرق اجنبيه للبحث عن المفقودين
وجثث الضحايا جراء السيول في درنه شرقي
ليبيا وقال الهلال الاحمر الليبي ان فرق
الانقاذ تواجه تحديات كبيره في عمليات
انتشال جثث الضحايا من البحر كما ناشد
ناشطون ميدانيون دول العالم
بتقديم دعم لوجستي للبحث عن الضحايا
التفاصيل في التقرير التالي
دارنا المدينه المنكوبه تنوء تحت حمل ثقيل
مسؤولون صحيون يحذرون من ان الامال في
العثور على ناجينا تتضاءل لكن فرق الانقاذ
تواصل جهودها لانتشال الاحياء اينما وجدوا
كل هذه الجهود لا تزال قاصره عن الاقتراب
من طي صفحه الاستجابه الاولى للكارثه
فالوضع مفشع والفرق المختصه غير كافيه
للاحاطه بحجم الفاجعه
نطالب العالم انهم يساندوناره
احنا نطالب العالم
واللي في البحر
لا يزال التحدي الاقصى في درنه انتشال جثث
الضحايا من البحر
[موسيقى]
صعبه شويه يعني التعامل معها
المتطورين بعمليه مسح على الشواطي ولو كان
في موجود اي جثه حاجه تعامله معها
بالكيفيه المضبوطه الهلال
الاحمر والصعوبات في التعامل مع الجثث
لغياب التقنيات الاساسيه لكن الحياه دوما
ما تكون اقوى فالهلال الاحمر الليبي اكد
انه انتشل سيدتين على قيد الحياه بعد مرور
قرابه اسبوع على الكارثه فما العوامل التي
تسهم في نجاه العالقين تحت الانقاض في
الكوارث الطبيعيه
الوصول الى المياه عامل اساسي تشير
تقديرات الى ان المده التي يمكن للانسان
ان يبقى فيها حيا دون ماء تراوح بين ثلاثه
ايام وسبعه ايام مع الاخذ بعين الاعتبار
درجات الحراره وبالتالي كميه السوائل التي
يفقدها جسم الانسان الوصول الى الهواء
اساسي ايضا وذلك يعتمد على البقعه التي
علق بها الشخص سواء تتيح ممرا للهواء او
كانت مغلقه لتفادي الاختناق عدم وجود
اصابات يساعد بدوره في استدامه الحياه
وغياب حطام ثقيل فوق جسم الشخص العالق
عامل مهم ايضا يبقى ان توفر الطعام يزيد
من فرص النجاه يمكن الاستمرار دونه اسابيع
لكن بالنسبه الى الغالبيه العظمى قد تقتصر
المهله على بضعه ايام كما يلعب عمر
الانسان دورا في البقاء على قيد الحياه
لفتره اطول وتزيد هذه المده بغياب امراض
مزمنه
ومن داخل درنا ينضم الان الينا مراسلنا
تامر الصمادي تامر ضعنا في سوره
اخر الاوضاع في درنه
بالفعل ليله الاوضاع مزريه للغايه صعبه
بشكل كبير لا سيما مع مرور الوقت الوقت هو
عامل حاسم فيما يتعلق بعمليات انتشال
الجثث من تحت الانقاض من قلب اليابسه من
قلب البحر
ويبدو ان هذا الوقت لم يسعف فرق الانقاذ
نحن نتحدث عن اليوم الثامن على بدء
الفيضانات او على وقوع الفيضانات وساعات
قليله تفصلنا عن اليوم التاسع طاقه الامل
تضيق كثيرا بالنسبه لفريق الانقاذ في
امكانيه الوصول الى احياء تحت الركام
الهلال الاحمر الليبي كان يتحدث بشكل واضح
خلال الساعات الماضيه وقال بان نسبه
العثور على احياء هي لا تتجاوز خمسه
بالمئه ضئيله وضئيله للغايه وفي مقابل كل
ذلك التحدي الابرز هو المتعلق
بالامكانيات التي ما تزال ضعيفه هشه
بالنسبه لفرق الانقاذ لا سيما الفرق
الليبيه منها هنالك اعتماد كثير على
الادوات البدائيه لاستخراج الجثث ولرفع
الانقاض وكميات الركام الكبيره رغم وجود
فرق عربيه ودوليه الا ان كل تلك الفرق
المشاركه في رفع الانقاض في المدينه لا لن
تتمكن وهو ما يمكن ان يرصد بشكل واضح من
رفع كامل هذه الانقاض في وقت قياسي الحديث
عن ان الامر قد يستغرق شهرا وربما اكثر
ولذلك تتصاعد الدعوات الرسميه والاهليه
بالاضافه الى المنظمات الاغاثيه الموجوده
بالمدينه بالمناشدات بان يتم ارسال مزيد
من الفرق لاسيما المتخصصه منها بالاضافه
الى ارسال المعدات ذات الكفاءه العاليه
للتعامل مع مثل هذا الحادث غير المسبوق
وغير المحوج في الحقيقه ونحن نتحدث عن
الطاقه الامل التي تضيق كثيرا فهي
تبقى تتسع بالنسبه لذوي الضحايا هؤلاء لا
يسلمون بان عائلاتهم التي تحت الانقاض قد
قضت وقد باتت جثه تنتشر رائحتها في
الارجاء نحن قدمنا قبل ساعات قليله من
اخطر المناطق في درنه وهي منطقه الوادي
ومنطقه حي الصحابه هذه المنطقه التي سويت
الى حد كبير ليلى في الارض نتحدث عن مباني
كثيره وطرقات كثيره واحياء تم طمسها
بالكامل جرفت اقتلعت اشتدت من البسيطه وتم
القذف فيها في البحر الخطر الاكبر بالنسبه
لفرقه الانقاذ كما تحدثنا الى العديد منهم
هو الامر المتعلق بالبحر هنالك الاف الجثث
التي لا زالت عالقه تحت البحر في قلب
البحر لا سيما تلك العائلات التي كانت تهم
بالفرار بمركباتها لكن ذلك لم يسعفها باتت
الان في قلب البحر الامكاني صحيحه قليله
والخطر الاكبر نهايه هو المتعلق بامكانيه
حدوث الوباء والامراض وهو ما دفع السلطات
الى التلويح بقرار اخلاء المدينه او اجزاء
كبيره منها في مقبل الساعات سواء كان 5%
حتى لو كان الواحد في الميه تامر سنبقى
نتمسك بطاقه الامل هذه لنسمع نسمع اخبار
طيبه منك انت تامر وسط كل هذه الماسي
واخبار الدمار اشكرك جزيلا من دردشه
هذا واظهرت صور جويه خاصه للجزيره حجم
الدمار الذي حل بسدي وادي بو منصور ودرنا
جراء اعصار دانيال الذي دمرهما في التاسع
من الشهر الجاري انهار السد الاول للمعروف
بسد وادي بو منصور بعد تجمع
115 مليون متر مكعب من المياه خلفه رغم ان
سعته التخزينيه تبلغ اثنين وعشرين مليون
ونصف المليون متر مكعب من المياه انهار
السد الثاني المعروف بسدرنا والذي تبلغ
سعته التخزينيه مليونا ونصف المليون متر
مكعب بعد ان تراكمت عليه المياه اثرا
انهيار السد الاول
وفي غضون ذلك اعلن جهاز تنفيذ واداره
مشروع النهر الصناعي وشركه النهر لتصنيع
الانابيب والانشاء البدء في اعمال بناء
جسر مؤقت يربط شرق مدينه درنه بغربها وقال
الجهاز ان الجسر سيكون عرضه عرضه عفوا
واحدا وعشرين مترا
لاستخدامه كقناه تصريف للمياه وذلك
باستخدام ثمانيه عشر انبوبا خرسانيا
بداخله
هذا وقلم مدير فرع الهلال الاحمر في
الزنتان عبد الباسط عبد السلام ان فرق
الانقاذ في درنه تواجه تحديا في التعامل
مع الجثث التي ما تزال داخل البحر وخلال
مداخله مع الجزيره اكد عبد السلام ان
الهلال الاحمر انقذ امراتين امس بعد نحو
اسبوع من كارثه الاعصار
قام فريق الانتشار الجثث التابعه لفرع
الزيتون
الامس بانتشابيه بانقاذ فتيات
من داخل البيوت المنهاره جراء الفيضانات
التي حدثت في مدينه درنا اما بخصوص موضوع
الجسد فكل يوم متواجدين يعني في الميدان
وفيه كل يوم جثه يعني
[موسيقى]
كفريق الهلال الاحمر او الافرقه الاخرى
المتواجده داخل مدينه الداخله خصوص موضوع
الجثث المتواجده داخل البحر صعبه شويه
يعني التعامل معها ولكن بتعليمات من
القياده العامه للقوات المسلحه نقوم
بمشاركتهم في الغرفه فيقوم الشباب بعمليات
المتطوعين بعمليه مسح على الشواطي ولو كان
في موجود اي جده وحاجه تعاملوا معها
بالكيفيه المزبوطه اما بخصوص موضوع التحلل
هذه يعني من اختصاص السلطات المحليه يعني
نحن بتعليمات بس فقط يعني ننتشر فقط يعني
يتم عليها البلاغ او ينتشر فيها فقط
للمكان المخصص لها
وينضموا الان الينا من الطرابلس رئيس بعثه
الامم المتحده للدعم في ليبيا عبد الله
باتيلي اهلا وسهلا بك سيد عبد الله في
الحصاد
فهمت انا كزرت عدد من المناطق المنكوبه في
الشرق الليبي حدثنا عن اهم ما استوقفك
سواء من حيث الوضع الماساوي للاهالي ووضع
الجثث او من
ناحيه المساعدات والجهود المقدمه
النور
والنقطه الاهم التي يجب ان تلحظها هو
او هي
الدمار في ذاك المكان
واطلعت على اثار الدمار الذي لحق بالمدينه
وبكل تاكيد
ان حجم الدمار
هائل بالفعل
المباني سويت بالارض في تلك المدينه
وضغط
الامواج من المحيط ادى الى تسويه هذه
المباني بالارض وطبعا نشعر
بالحزن الشديد لانه لا يمكن ان نتخيل هذه
الصور بالفعل ومدى فداحه الاضرار بالنسبه
الى
سكاني درنه الاشخاص الذين نجوا من هذه
الكارثه الناجون عندما نعاين وجوها
الناجين
بالفعل
هو امر يصعب علي ان اصفه ان اصفه لكم
نتحدث عن بشر فقدوا كل شيء
وبكل تاكيد هنا يتبادر الى دهننا السؤال
لماذا يحصل هذا الامر هذه كارثه طبيعيه
نعم بكل تاكيد ولكن ماذا بالنسبه الى
مسؤوليه البشر ازاء هذه الكارثه الطبيعيه
على الاقل عندما نعاين
حجم الاضرار والدمار الهائل
يتبادر الى ذهننا سؤال هل كان بالامكان
القيام باي شيء لتفادي هذه الكارثه او
للتخفيف من هول الدمار ومن خجل
سؤال اريد لو سمحت ان تجيبنا عليه انت
يعني هل كان بالامكان فعلا التجنب هذا
الحجم من الاضرار
في الحقيقه
افترض ذلك
انه اذا ما اختر الناس بشكل مسبق لو اعطي
اعطيت المعلومات الصحيحه للناس من قبل
لكان بالامكان التخفيف من حجم الدمار هذا
رايي هل هناك جهه بعينها تتحمل المسؤوليه
هنا برايك
في الحقيقه لقد استمعت
الى
ان السلطات تجري تحقيقا بالنسبه الى
مسببات هذه الكارثه ونامل ان التقارير
التي سوف تنتج عن هذه التحقيقات نتامل ان
تكون شامله وموضوعيه في الوقت نفسه وايضا
ان تشير هذه التقارير الى
نطاق المسؤوليات سواء كانت مسؤوليات فرديه
او جماعيه
وبكل تاكيد نحن نتحدث عن كارثه طبيعيه
ولكن هناك في الوقت نفسه مسؤوليه على
عاتقي البشر في هذه الازمه
الرئيس بعثه الامم المتحده للدعم في ليبيا
وهذا ما اريد ان اسالك عنه عن الدعم كيف
تقيم الدعم المقدم حاليا لليبيا في هذه
الظ روف
الشعب الليبي
تم حشده او حشد منذ البدايه وانخرط في
جهود منذ البدايه واود ان اعرب عن تقدير
لجهودي المتطوعين من كل انحاء ليبيا الذين
تقاتلوا
وتظافروا في جهد تازري لدعم المنكوبين
والمتضررين وهو
امرا غير مسبوق اذا حجم هذه الكارثه غير
مسبوق في التاريخ الليبي بالاضافه الى ذلك
نشيد بالدعم الدولي من كل انحاء العالم
دعما لشعب دارنا الامم المتحده منذ
البدايه انخرطت بجهد لدعم سكاني درنه بشكل
كامل وكالات الامم المتحده حشدت من اجل
تقديم الدعم ونحن لا نزال في طور التنسي
فيما بين وكالات الامم المتحده وايضا مع
الجهات الدوليه واشيد بجهود اولئك الذين
عملوا بلا كلل وبكل كد وجد وجهد
ووصلوا الليله بالنهار من اجل مساعدتي
سكاني درنه وليس فقط سكان دارنا بل
سكان المناطق المتضرره في ليبيا رئيس بعثه
الامم المتحده للدعم في ليبيا شكرا
وينضم الينا كذلك من طرابلس مراسلنا احمد
خليفه احمد ضعنا في صوره اخر المعلومات
والمواقف من طرابلس
منذ قليل ليلى انتهى المؤتمر الصحفي
اليومي للفريق الحكومي للطوارئ والاستجابه
السريعه وهو فريق تابع لحكومه الوحده
الوطنيه هذا اليوم كان بحضور ثلاثه وزراء
وهم وزير الحكم وهم وزراء الحكم المحلي
والتعليم التقني
والتربيه والتعليم العام لكن وايضا كان
معهم الناطق الرسمي باسم الحكومه لكن ابرز
ومسؤلان اخران لكن ابرز ما ورد في هذا
المؤتمر الصحفي هو ما اعلنه وزير الحكم
المحلي بدر الدين التومي الذي قال على
سبيل المثال ان شركه الكهرباء تحقق كل يوم
تقدما في مدينه درنه وهذا يعني بطبيعه
الحال بدا عوده الاتصالات الى وتيرتها
الطبيعيه ايضا قال ان المركز الوطني
لمكافحه الامراض ولديه فريق حكومي هناك في
مدينه درنه باع ان هذا المركز هو مركز
حكومي مركزه هنا في العاصمه طرابلس قال
سجل هذا المركز انخفاضا في حالات التلوث
او حالات التسمم بسبب تلوث المياه في درنه
الناطق الرسمي باسم الحكومه محمد حموده
قال ان الهيئه العامه للبحث والتعرف على
المفقودين انتشلت 20 جثه من البحر اليوم
وقال ان هناك فريقا من الجيش اليوناني وصل
الى مدينه درنه للمشاركه في عمليات انتشال
الجثث
والانقاذ اما وزير التعليم فقال ان هناك
114 مدرسه في مناطق الجبل الاخضر شرق
ليبيا تضررت بشكل متفاوت جراء هذه السيول
والفيضانات في وقت سابق الليله مصلحه
الجسور والطرق من مركزها هنا في العاصمه
طرابلس اعلنت احصائيات كبيره لدمار البنيه
التحتيه ودمار الجسور في مدينه درنه سواء
التي داخل مدينه درنه او التي تربط مدينه
درنه بمدن اخرى كمدن سوسه وكمدن شحات لكن
جميع الجسور الموجوده في مدينه درنه دمرت
بالكامل وفق ما اعلنته مصلحه الطرق
والجسور وهذا الدمار بطبيعه الحال لان هذه
الجسور تمر فوق وادي درنه الذي اجتاحته
السيوله هذه تقريبا ابرز التطورات ليله
خلال الساعتين الاخيرتين مساء هذا اليوم
اشكرك جزيلا احمد على العموم سيكون لنا
لقاء خاص مع وزير الموارد المائيه
وسيحدثنا عن وضع الجسور والطرق التي يتم
التعامل معها على العموم اشكرك حتى الان
على هذه المعلومات من طرابلس
الان الى مستجدات الزلزال في المغرب
[موسيقى]
جهود الانقاذ والاغاثه لمجابهه تداعيات
زلزال الحوز مستمره ما تستمر عمليات البحث
عن ناجين وانتشال جثث الضحايا لليوم
الحادي عشر على التوالي من وقع الزلزال
كما اعلنت السلطات المغربيه مواصله عمليات
فتح الطرق الجبليه المؤديه الى القرى
النائيه المتضرره من الزلزال وقال رئيس
الحكومه المغربيه عزيز خنوش ان تاهيل
المناطق المتضرره سياخذ في الاعتبار تقويه
البنيه التحتيه والرفع من جوده الخدمات
العموميه
كذلك تواصل الهيئات الاغاثيه جهودها
لايواء المنكوبين وعلاج الجرحى يتزامن ذلك
وبدء تفعيل البرنامج الحكومي الطارئ
لايواء من فقدوا منازلهم
وكانت الحكومه المغربيه اعلنت اليوم
استئناف الدراسه في الاقاليم الخمسه التي
ضربها زلزال الحوز وحضر العديد من الطلبه
اليوم الى خيام تم تجهيزها كمدارس مؤقته
في حين نقل عدد اخر من الطلبه من منطقه
ثلاث اليعقوب ومناطق اخرى الى مدينه مراكش
بعد تعذر انشاء مدارس هناك
بعد عشره ايام على وقوع زلزال الحوز قررت
الحكومه المغربيه استئناف العمليه
التعليميه في المناطق المتضرره اكثر من
500 وحده تعليميه كانت عامله في تلك
المنطقه
استبدل جزء كبير منها مؤقتا بالخيام اليوم
تم استقبال الطلاب الطالبات وكانوا الحضور
متميز فقد 80 في المئه وكل الاطر التربوي
الاداريه حاضره في المؤسسه لاستقبال
للطلاب بالطبع كانت كان كان الدخول
كان التركيز فيه على جانب الوجداني النفسي
من اجل العوده
لعجله الحياه بشكل تدريجي
احدى مدارس اطفال المرحله الابتدائيه هنا
في امزميز
كان لابد من تعريف الاطفال بما حدث وشرح
اسباب عدم عودتهم الى مقاعدهم القديمه
تسعى السلطات الى تجاوز صدمه الزلزال
واثاره ولعل الاعلان عن عوده الدراسه في
المناطق التي ضربها الزلزال مؤشر على هذا
السعيد لكن الامر لا يخلو من صعوبات
نتوجه الى احدى القرى النائيه في منطقه
جاط في اقليم شيشاوه
خلف هؤلاء عن المدرسه اليوم
الفاقه التي زادها الزلزال كانت سببا لعدم
قدره بعضهم على الذهاب الى المدرسه
وللبعض اسباب اخرى
بمدرسه انس بن مالك طيب مدارس اليوم بدات
باقي الاقسم مشققين
طلبوا الامر وقتا ليعتاد التلاميذ مدارسهم
الجديده
خاصه اولئك الذين غيب الموت بعض زملائه
ترى الحكومه ان المهم الان هو ان لا
ينقطعوا عن الدراسه
فاولويه التعليم لا تقل اهميه عن مهمه
الايواء عمر الحاج الجزيره من بدله امزميز
جنوب مراكش
والان من منطقه اسني في اقليم الحوز ينضم
الينا مراسلنا المختار العلاوي المختار
اهلا بك يعني من خلفك تبدو مقاعد دراسيه
واضحه انها تجمع ربما كدليل لعوده
مظهر من مظاهر الحياه الى طبيعتها على
الاقل هذا ضعه في سياقه وايضا في صوره
محاولات اخرى
لاعاده الحياه لطبيعتها عندك
بالفعل ليله الجهود تتواصل وكان واضحا في
عده مناطق ان هناك التوجه كبير لاعاده
التلاميذ في اسرع وقت الى مقاعد الدراسه
ما وراءنا هو عباره عن قاعات متنقله
سيواصل فيها التلاميذ عما قريب دراستهم
وبالتحديد تلاميذ المناطق
المنكوبه هنا الان يتم تجهيز هذه القاعات
بالطاولات وايضا بالكهرباء وبالضروريات
بالصبوره
بكل ما يتعلق بالعمليه التعلميه او عمليه
التمدرس
والاشغال قائمه على قدم الوساق منذ ساعات
الصباح الاولى في هذه المنطقه لدينا
تقريبا
حوالي ست وحدات متنقله هنا تم وضعها من
اجل توفير البنيه التحتيه لهؤلاء التلاميذ
المنكوبين من اجل مواصله الدراسه هذا نوع
اول النوع الثاني كان هو الخيام الخيانه
وكان اليوم ربما العنوان الابرز والخيام
او المدرسه في الخيمه تم نصب الكثير
العشرات من الخيمات في عده مناطق واصبحنا
نشاهد مثلا 30 خيمه هي عباره عن مدرسه هذا
الجزء الثاني من المشهد
والجزء الثالث كان هو نقل
مدارس بتلاميذتها باطرها بادارييها من
المناطق المنكوبه كما هو الحال في ايغيل
والضواحي الى مدينه مراكش حيث توجد مؤسسات
دراسيه تم تخصيصها لتكون لهؤلاء التلاميذ
بموازاهه مع التلاميذ العاديين غفرت له في
المقابل
المطاعم وايضا المبيت لكن هنا في هذه
المناطق التي بعيده عن مراكش عند وضع
الخيام يشتكي الاهالي من قضيه النقل
المدرسي يدعو الاهالي الى ضروره توفير
النقل المدرسي ويدعو ايضا الاهالي هنا
السلطات المغربيه الى توفير المطاعم مما
سيساعد ابنائهم على الالتحاق لكننا خلال
ساعات الصباح الاولى هنا في اسني وايضا في
مراكش لاحظنا حزنا واضحا على هؤلاء
التلاميذ جزء منهم لا يزال تحت الصدمه
خصوصا وان بعضهم فقد الاب فقد الام فقد
الاخ فقد الاخت لا تزال مشاهد الدمار
والصدم وحجم الهوله الموجود هناك في
المناطق المتضرره كبيره ولهذا وان انطلقت
الدراسه هذا اليوم في الحقيقه لم تكن هناك
دراسه كانت فقط جلسات للاستماع حاول
الاساتذه ان يجالسوا هؤلاء التلاميذ ان
يستمعوا اليهم ان يخففوا عنهم من ورقه
الحال بالاضافه الى دور لعبه وايضا
المساعدون الاجتماعيون الذين حاولوا ايضا
التخفيفه تخفيفه تخفيف
ومهمه نستطيع ان نتصور ما يمر به هؤلاء
التلاميذ وما تعنيه لهم هذه الخطوه شكرا
لك المختار العبداوي من اسني في الحوس
[موسيقى]
وصل الى العاصمه القطريه السجناء
الامريكيون الخمسه الذين كانوا محتجزين في
ايران تنفيذا لصفقه تبادل سجناء بين
الولايات المتحده وايران بواسطه قطريه وقد
وصل المفرج عنهم الى مطار الدوحه على متن
طائره تابعه للخطوط الجويه القطريه
تتضمن صفقه التبادل ايضا الافراج عن خمسه
سجناء ايرانيين في الولايات المتحده اضافه
الى وصول اموال ايرانيه مفرج عنها من
كوريا الجنوبيه الى حسابات ايرانيه مسجله
في مصرفين قطريين
رحله الطائره القطريه القادمه من طهران
الى الدوحه استغرقت حوالي ساعتين لكنها
تطلبت نحو عامين من جوالات تفاوض خاضتها
الوساطه القطريه كان خمسه امريكيين واسرهم
على متن طائره الخطوط القطريه وكان في
استقبالهم مسؤولون قطريون وامريكيون في
مطار الدوحه الدولي
الدبلوماسيه القطريه بهذه الخطوه نجحت في
تخفيف حده التوتر بين واشنطن وطهران اذ ان
تنفيذ تبادل السجناء فتح المجال امام
المضي في مزيد من التفاهمات والعوده الى
خطه العمل المشتركه وحلحلت العديد من
الملفات الشائكه بين الطرفين وهو الامر
الذي اكده وزير الخارجيه القطري محمد بن
عبد الرحمن ال ثاني الاتفاق تضمن ايضا
تحويل اموال ايرانيه الى حسابات مصرفيه في
الدوحه بلغت 6 مليارات دولار ستشرف عليها
دوله قطر الاتفاق تضمن العديد من الضمانات
فيما يتعلق خاصه بانزال المالي
على تفعيل هذه القناه المصرفيه الانسانيه
من الدوحه لصالح تحديدا المواد الغذائيه
والادويه والاجهزه الطبيه والمنتجات
الزراعيه بما يضمن ان يتم استخدام هذه
الاموال حفرا في الجانب الانساني وفيما
يعود بالنسبه طبعا على مواطنيه الجمهوريه
الاسلاميه وهذا هو الامر طبعا الذي تم
التوقف عليه بين الطرفين ووفق ما ذهبت
اليه الخارجيه القطريه فان هذا الاتفاق
ليس نهايه بذاتها بقدر ما يفتح افاقا
لتناول ملفات كثيره اخرى تتطلب نفس
المثابره الدبلوماسيه مستقبلا اتمام صفقه
تبادل السجناء بين واشنطن وطهران وتحويل
سته مليارات دولار من الاموال الايرانيه
المجمده الى حسابات مصرفيه في الدوحه ثمره
لوساطه قطر التي استطاعت من خلالها تقريب
وجهات النظر بين ايران وامريكا وفتح قنوات
اتصال ساهمت في تدليل كثير من الع قبات
بين الجانبين سار رشيد الجزيره الدوحه
هذا وقال رئيس الوزراء وزير الخارجيه
القطريه الشيخ محمد بن عبد الرحمن الثاني
انه يامل ان يمهد الاتفاق الامريكيه
الايراني بشان تبادل السجناء المزيد من
التفاهمات واضاف في منشور على منصه اكس
انه يتوجه بالشكر لطرفي الاتفاق ولشركاء
قطر الذين ساهموا في انجاحه لا سيما سلطنه
عمان واكد رئيس الوزراء وزير الخارجيه
القطري هنا قطر مستمره في المساهمه في كل
ما من شانه تعزيز امن المنطقه والعالم
هذا وكان وزير الدوله في وزاره الخارجيه
القطريه محمد الخليفي قال ان الاتفاق بدا
بالافراج عن السجناء من البلدين
وتحويل اموال ايرانيه الى حسابات مصرفيه
في الدوحه واكد الخليفي في تصريح لوكاله
الانباء ان تنفيذ هذا الاتفاق دلاله على
مكانه قطر كشريك دولي موثوق به في مجال
الوساطه والثقه الاطراف كافه في نزاهتها
وحياتها كما اعرب الخليفي عن امل دوله قطر
في ان يفضي التنفيذ الكامل للاتفاق بين
الولايات المتحده وايران الى تفاهمات اكبر
تشمل العوده الى خطه العمل الشامله
المشتركه
ومن جانبه ثمن الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
صفقه التبادل وقال انها ستعيد اخيرا خمسه
امريكيين كانوا مسجونين في ايران الى
وطنهم هذا وقال وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
انتي
اتفاق تبادل السجناء مع ايران منفصل عن
القضايا الاخرى مع طهران بما في ذلك قضيه
احياء الاتفاق النووي واشار بلنكن في
مؤتمر صحفي في نيويورك الى ان تركيز بلاده
انصب على اعاده المواطنين الامريكيين
المحتجزين في ايران
دعوني اكون واضحا للغايه ان هذه العمليه
والمحادثات الخاصه باطلاق سراح الامريكيين
كانت دائما في مسار منفصل عن القضايا
الاخرى وبغض النظر عما يحدث في الجهود
الراميه الى العوده للاتفاق النووي فقد
ركزنا على العمل بشكل مستقل على اعاده
الامريكيين الى بلادهم وهذا لا يعني اي
شيء في علاقاتنا مع ايران وما زلنا مصممين
على اتخاذ اي خطوات ضروريه لمعالجه تصرفات
ايران في مختلف المجالات وفي نفس الوقت لا
نزال نعتقد ان الدبلوماسيه هي افضل طريقه
للوصول الى نتيجه فعاله بخصوص البرنامج
النووي الايراني
قال الرئيس الايراني ابراهيم رئيسي ان
اطلاق سراح الامريكيين الخمسه مزدوجيه
الجنسيه كان عملا انسانيا بحتا واضاف رئيس
يعقب وصوله الى نيويورك لحضور الجمعيه
العامه للامم المتحده انا من الام ممكن
القيام باجراءات انسانيه اخرى في المستقبل
بين طهران و واشنطن وبدورها تمنت وزاره
الخارجه الايرانيه دوره دوله قطر المؤثر
في عمليه انتقال اصول ماليه ايرانيه
وتبادل للسجناء مع واشنطن ووجهت الشكر
لسلطنه عمان وسويسرا تحديدا على جهودهما
وقالت الخارجيه الايرانيه في بياننا انفاق
الاموال المحرره في قطر سيتم بناء على
احتياجات ايران واولويتها
تقرير فوزي بشرى
بعد كثير من تراكمات الخطاب العدائي بين
ايران والولايات المتحده الامريكيه ورغم
الثقه المفقوده بين الجانبين وكثره
الملفات الشائكه لم يعدم البلدان النفاذ
من اضيق الابواب الى تفاهمات عبر الحوار
تجعل الصعب ممكنا وما كان للحوار ان يتم
لولا دبلوماسيه قطريه منحها الطرفان
ثقتهما وكان من نتائجها ما شهدته الدوحه
من وصول خمسه سجناء امريكيين قادمين من
طهران الى قطر للذهاب من بعد الى الولايات
المتحده
ويشكل الافراج عن السجناء الامريكيين
مقابل خمسه سجناء ايرانيين من السجون
الامريكيه تتويا لحوارات طويله توسطت فيها
قطر الطائره التي جاءت بالامريكيين الخمسه
الى الدوحه ستقل ثلاثه من السجناء
الايرانيين المحررين الى بلادهم بعد ان
تخلف منهما اثنان مؤثرين التوجه الى بلد
اخر قطر التي حصدت ثمره جهودها قال رئيس
وزرائها ووزير خارجيتها الشيخ محمد بن عبد
الرحمن ال ثاني ان بلاده مستمره في كل ما
من شانه تعزيز امن المنطقه والعالم ولا
يقف الاتفاق بين الجانبين عند تبادل
السجناء بل يضمك جزء منه فك الحظر المفروض
على اموال ايرانيه تبلغ نحو سته مليارات
دولار
وقد تم بالفعل وفقا لافادات المسؤولين
القطريين والايرانيين ايداع هذه الاموال
في بنوك قطريه تحت ما تسميه واشنطن
بالقناه الانسانيه التي تمكن الايرانيين
من السحب منها لاغراض انسانيه فقط
وحذرت الولايات المتحده من انه في حال
خروج الصرف عن هذه الاغراض وهي مما يتصل
بحاجه ايران الى المواد الغذائيه
والدوائيه والزراعيه فان واشنطن ستعود الى
فرض التجميل على الحسابات
واياما كانت العقبات التي قد تنشا في
تعريف ما هو انساني فان الاتفاق يمثل
اختراقا كبيرا للدبلوماسيه في كسر جمود
العلاقه الايرانيه الامريكيه مع ضخامه
رصيدها من سوء الظن ومن التربص فما اكثر
ما وقف البلدان على حافه المواجهه في مياه
الخليج والمواجهه العسكريه هي ما تحرض
عليه اسرائيل امريكا للقضاء على برنامج
ايران النووي وكانت اسرائيل قد رفضت
الصفقه التي تمت بين الولايات المتحده
وايران زعمه انها تشكل دعما لما تسميه
اسرائيل الارهاب الايراني وتعزيزا لقدرات
طهران وهو امر سيكون بمثابه تراجع خطير عن
استراتيجيه الاحتواء الامريكي بحسب
اسرائيل الغضب الاسرائيلي الذي فشل في
تعطيل الصفقه كشف عن تقاطع للمصالح
الامريكيه الاسرائيليه ربما لمره بهذا
الوضوح من جانب اخر بدت الصفقه التي سعت
فيها قطر بيانا في امكانيه الذهاب ابعد
الى مقاربه القضيه الاكثر تعقيدا وهي ملف
ايران النووي الذي بقي منذ خروج واشنطن
منه على عهد الرئيس السابق دون ترامب سببا
لتعزيم العلاقه مع واشنطن والغرب تاره ومع
الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه الذراع
الفني للقوه العظمى لحراسه نادي الدول
النوويه ما يدخل عليها داخل الا عنوه
واقتدارا صنع الهند وباكستان وكوريا
الشماليه
[موسيقى]
واذا كانت الدبلوماسيه القطريه ستجد دفعا
وتحفيزا بما حققت من نجاح في صفقه تحرير
الانفس والاموال فان ايران ايضا ربما وجدت
السبيل الدبلوماسيه اكثر جدوى واعجل فائده
انه براح يوفر طاقتها في السياسه وفي
الاقتصاد ويجعل ما يبدو مستحيلا امرا
ممكنا
ينضم الان الينا من واشنطن الدكتور خليل
العناني استاذ العلوم السياسيه والعلاقات
الدوليه وكبير الباحثين في جامعه جوشتاون
اهلا دكتور خليل ايضا
بعد نحو سبع جولات تفوضيه وعام كامل من
الجهود تم التوصل الى هذه الصفقه صفقه
تبادل السجناء ولكن ما قيمتها فعليا في
سياق العلاقات بين البلدين
طبعا صفقه مهمه جدا نتكلم على دولتيما
تاريخ من العداء الطويل على مدار العلاقه
الاربعين سنه وبالتالي عندما تحت هذه
الصفقه انا حدث عن اختراق مهم جدا اولا في
العلاقات الثنائيه بين الطرفين ثانيا في
تهدئه الاجواء في المنطقه العربيه بشكل
الاوسط في مقلق عليه
يعتبر تحول مهم جدا يسحب كل ما يتعلق
امكانيه وجود اي وجود اي نوع من الواجهه
العسكريه بين الطرفين او توتر في ملفات
اخرى وبالتالي نحن اذا تحول في المنطقه
تحول نوعي الى حد بعيد قد يؤدي قد يمهد
شكل اخر الى وجود نوع من التواصل فيما
يتعلق من ملفات اخرى وبعد كده طبعا الامر
سابق لاوانه لكن بشكل عام كل اتفاق يتم
التواصل بين الطرفين
واختبر
ان التصريحات التي صدرت عن المسؤولين
الامريكيين حتى الان تخفض من سقف التوقعات
الى حد كبير بشان هذه الصفقه حتى ان جون
كربي يعني اخر مقاله قال لن تؤثر على الاط
لاق لن يكون لها اي تاثير على العلاقات
بين البلدين كيف يفسر هذا برايك
يفسر لحد بعيد بوجود صراع داخلي وخلاف
داخلي وهناك حاله تربص من حزب الجمهور
الديمقراطيين بمعنى اخر هناك رفض بشكل او
باخر من قبل الجمهوريين لاي تقدم في
العلاقات الايرانيه الامريكيه على اعتبار
عده عوامل العام الاول انه اي اموال قد
تصرف ايران قد تستخدم فيما يسمى بالقيام
بدور تخريب في المنطقه قد يتعلق الامر
ايضا بدعم الدور الاقليمي لايرانه بتدعم
حلفائها الممتدين من العراق وحتى اليمن قد
تتعلق الامر ايضا باسرائيل وبالتالي
محاوله التقليل من ما حدث اليوم هو يعتبر
في اطار الصراع والمناكفه السياسيه بين
الجمهوريين الذين يرفضون بشكل او باخر وقد
رفضوا من قبل عندما قام ايضا باعطاء اموال
لايران او على الاقل رفع التجنيد اموال
ايرانيه محتجزه في بنوك عالميه في مقابل
اتفاق النووي في عام 2015 تم ايضا نقد
انتقال ذلك الموضوع وتم الهجوم على بوابه
باعتباره يشجع ايران على المدير قدما في
ستاتها ما تسمى الى حد بعيد
اوصلتني بهذا الكلام الى نقطه اخرى يعني
لماذا لا نفترض ان الموضوع كله بالنسبه
للرئيس بايدن حاليا هو تسجيل نقطه لصالحه
بالنسبه للانتخابات المقبله خصوصا انه
يعاني من انخفاض كبير في شعبيته ومن ثم
يعني الافراج عن السجناء بهذه الطريقه
الان يعتبر لصالحه ليس اكثر ولا اقل ولا
يعني نكبر الموضوع اكثر من ذلك ما رايك
بلا شك اي مكسب سياسي يعتبر انجاز يعني
عندما يتم الافراج عن خمس سجناء امريكيين
كانوا محتاجين على الاقل منذ 7.8 اعوام في
ايران الذي اعتبر انجاز سياسي يتم
استخدامه شكل باخر في التراع في اطار
الصراع السياسي داخليا هذا امر ليس هناك
عيب في ذلك بالعكس هناك تشجيع على ذلك
بمعنى اخر عندما تنجح صفقه هذه كهذه يعتبر
اضافه للسجل بايدن نعم هناك بعض الاخفاقات
لكن هناك نجاحات تحسب اليه وبالتالي مهما
قيل عن الامر نحن ازاء صفقه تم اتمامها
بشكل اخر هناك دور مهم جدا لقطع الاطار
دور جاء من خلال وجود علاقات طيبه من
الطرفين قطر تمثل
عفوا حليف استراتيجي لامريكا من جهه
علاقات طيبه مع ايران وبالتالي قامت مهم
جدا في تهدئه الاوضاع وتمهيد الاوضاع لهذه
الصفقه المهمه جدا وبالتالي اي استخدام
هذا الموضوع امر مغرد جدا نحن
تستخدم فيها كثره اوراق وبالتالي ليس هناك
عيب في ذلك على الاطلاق
فانه يمكن فعلا البناء على هذه الخطوه
فعليا كيف يمكن البناء عليها ما الذي يمكن
ان نتوقعه
كخطوه تاليه برايك
بين الملفات الملف المتعلق بهذه الصفقه
مختلفه عن الملفات الاخرى بنتكلم على
الاقل اربع خمس ملفات اخرى هناك حاله توتر
امريكي راني فيها اولا ملف المتعلق بملف
النووي الايراني حتى هذه اللحظه هناك حاله
انسداد شبه كامل في هذا الملف نتيجه
لاسباب طبعا داخليه وخارجيه جزء منها
متعلق بوجود رفض اسرائيل ودور اسرائيل
المهم جدا في عرقله اي اتفاق بين الطرفين
الامر الاخر متعلق بالدور الاقليمي اليران
وهناك حتى هذه اللحظه عدم اتفاق على حجم
هذا الدور وعلى تاثير على مصالح الامريكيه
الامر الثاني المتعلق بالتعاون الايراني
الروسي خاص هناك وجود دعم روسي دعم ايراني
عفوا شكلها واخر لروسيا فيما يتعلق بحرب
على اوكرانيا وبالتالي هناك ملفات قد تبدو
معقده لكنه ما حدث اليوم قد يمثل نوعا ما
بدايه لتهدئه الصراعات بين الطرفين قد
يمثل تمهيد للدخول في مفاوضات على الاقل
فيما يتعلق بالتواصل الاتفاق ولو مؤقت
فيما يتعلق بالتلقي النووي يراني قد يؤدي
الى تهدئه الاوضاع قد نشهد شكله باخر
تهديد الاوضاع فيما يتعلق بالخليج العربي
وقد راينا على مدار الاسابيع حاله حشد
وتعبئه بين الطرفين لكنه تم تقليل منها
هناك ايضا خطوات ايرانيه فيما يتعلق
بتقليل حجم التخصيب اليورانيوم وبالتالي
اعطاء اشاره ايجابيه ان هناك امكانيه
وبالتالي نحن اليوم نحن ازاء مرحله اولى
من مفارقه تبدا مستقبلا فيما يتعلق بهذا
الملف خاص ملف بين الطرفين الفكره شكرا
دكتور خليل العناني العلوم السياسيه
والعلاقات الدوليه وكبير بحثي في جامعه
جورج تاوند من واشنطن شكرا لك
[موسيقى]
لان الى تطورات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا اذ
اعلن الجيش الاوكراني استعاده اكثر من
خمسه كيلومترات مربعه من الاراضي على
المحور الجنوبي للهجوم المضاد كما قال انه
السيطره على بلده كلشكا جنوب بخمت شرقيه
البلاد وفي المقابل قالت وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه ان المدفعيه الروسيه استهدفت
بضربات دقيقه مواقع للقوات الاوكرانيه قرب
بخموت الشرقي البلاد
ببطء لكن بثبات يمضي الهجوم الاوكراني
المضاد الذي انطلق مطلع حزيران يونيو
الماضي شرقا وجنوبا فرغم الصعوبات على
الخطوط الروسيه المحصنه تحرز مزيدا من
المكاسب وتستعيد مساحات جديده
تقدمت القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه بنجاح في
اتجاه بخموت في الشرق وتم تحرير منطقه عين
اندر ميفكا
ومن الجدير بالذكر انه لم يتم انشاء اي
قوه هجوميه في هذه المنطقه وتقوم قواتنا
بتنفيذ عمليات الهجوم بالقوات المخصصه
للدفاع وخلال الاسبوع الماضي تم تحرير
كيلومترين مربعين في قطاع بخموت الجيش
الاوكراني نشر مقطعا مصورا قال انه لعمليه
تمشيط بلده اندريم افكا بعد ان استعاد
السيطره قبل ذلك على بلده كالشيفكا جنوب
مدينه في اقليم دومباس شرقي البلاد بينما
يستمر تقدم القوات صوب بلده كوردو ميفكا
على نفس المحور لكن عمل القوات الاوكرانيه
شرقا يواجه ضربات مكثفه من الجيش الروسي
الذي اعلن ان مد وقصفت تلك القوات في محور
باخموت والحقت بها دمارا هائله وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه ذكرت في تقريرها اليومي ان
قواتها قصفت ايضا مواقع تخزين في اوكرانيا
لصواريخ ستورم شادو وذخائر اليورانيوم
المنظم وهما نوعان من الاسلحه تلقتهما من
بريطانيا وبينما تستمر على نحو شبه يوميا
الهجمات والهجمات المضاده باستخدام
المسيرات قالت السلطات المواليه لروسيا في
اقليم دونيسك معقل الانفصاليين في شرق
اوكرانيا ان غاره اوكرانيه الحقت اضرارا
بمبنى البلديه ومقر الحكومه المحليه لكن
دون اي خسائر بشريه
اقلت الحكومه الاوكرانيه نوابه وزير
الدفاع الاوكرانيه سته وابقت على منصب
النائب الاول للوزير ياتي القرار بعد
اسبوعين على تعيين رستم وميروس وزيرا
جديدا للدفاع بعد تقديم الوزير السابق
اليكسي
استقالته اثر شبهات بالفساد في الوزاره
اثرت انتقادات محليه ودوليه وقد وعد
الوزير الجديد بسلسله اصلاحات في وزاره
الدفاع
وبتنسيق المساعدات العسكريه الخارجيه
للجيش ولم تعلن الحكومه امكانيه اصدار اي
قرار بعد بشان اعاده تعيين المقالين في
مناصب جديده
ينضم الان الينا من جنيف العقيد الكسندر
فوترابير رئيس تحرير المجله العسكريه
السويسريه اهلا وسهلا بك سيد
وابدا بسؤالك عن هذه هذا الاحتفاء
الاوكراني باستعاده خمسه كيلومترات مربعه
في الجنوب
الاوكراني ما قيمه هذا الانجاز وهل فعلا
يستحق كل هذا الاحتفاء برايك
اذا ما عايننا
الاراضي التي حققتها القوات الاوكرانيه في
عمليتها الهجوميه من حيث الحجم هي محدوده
للغايه طبعا
العمليات فيها تحديات متعدده وهذا لا ياتي
بسياقي انتقاداتنا للقوات الاوكرانيه حيث
ان الجهود المبذوله اساسيه في مواجهه
القوات الروسيه من المفيد ان يتم
الاستحواذ على هذه الاراضي لان
القوات الروسيه بحاجه الى حشد
الاحتياط بشكل اضافي من اجل مواجهه
العمليات الاوكرانيه المضاده
فعليا في سياق يعني الهجوم المضاد ومدى
فعاليته وهل ياتي هذا الاعلان بهذه
الطريقه الان من الجانب الاوكراني في اطار
ربما نوع من الخطاب الداخلي اكثر
للتحفيزي ربما الطمئنه اكثر من اي شيء اخر
بالتاكيد هذه الخطابات تؤدي الى تعزيز
المعنويات وفيها رمزيه وكما سبق واسلفت
الفائده بنسبه لاوكرانيا هي ان القوات
الروسيه بحاجه الى تعزيز قواتها القوات
الاوكرانيه تضغط على الروس لكي يحرك
القوات الخاصه بهم باتجاه تلك المنطقه وان
ياتوا بالعديد من الاحتياط تحدث
عن جليل لرفع المعنويات
ولكن لوزير الدفاع نعرف انهم كانوا
متابعين للوزير الدفاع السابق ولكن بكل
الاحوال ايضا هذا يثير شيء من الفوضى
والربكه على الاقل في تصور كثيرون يتابعون
المشهد كثيرين
او الالتباس طبعا لست متاكدا بالنسبه الى
ذلك طبعا روسيا تحاول ان تستغل ذلك ما
نراه في اوكرانيا بكل تاكيد هو جزء من
اعاده تشكيل الحكومه والمناصب الحكوميه في
اوكرانيا وكما سبق وقلت في مرات متعدده في
مقابلات متعدده على قناتكم الكريمه يجب ان
نفصل بين القياده السياسيه من جهه
والقياده العسكريه من جهه اخرى ولكن
القياده العسكريه متهمه بكثير من الفساد
وهذا بناء يعني لا يمكن فصل الورقتين
عندما يكون الفساد في قلب القضيه
يمكنني ان اجيب
بتكرار الاجابه السابقه نتحدث عن مساله
سياسيه مساله الفساد مرتبطه
بعمليه التجنيد
وعدد الاشخاص الذين سمح لهم باللاي يلتحق
بالتجنيد ولكن الامر لا يرتبط بالقياده
العسكريه الاوكرانيه
على العموم اشكرك العقيد الكسندر ضد رفيع
الرئيس تحرير المجله العسكريه السويس
ريه وزير الخرجات السعوديه الامير فيصل بن
فرحان انه لن يكون هناك حل للصراع
الفلسطيني الاسرائيلي دون دوله فلسطينيه
مستقله واضاف في تصريحات للتلفزيون الرسمي
ان الناس بدات تفقد الامل في حل الدولتين
الاسرائيليين الفلسطينيه ونريد من خلال
المجهودات اعادتها الى الواجهه
وصل الى مستشفى مدينه باسكن الشرقي
موريتانيا عدد من المصابين في المعارك
الدائره يوم امس بين مقاتلي الحركات
الازوديه والجيش المالي في منطقه المالي
في منطقه ليره
عفوا اعتذر وقلت مصادر محليه للجزيره ان
ثمانيه جرحى نصفهم في حاله حرجه يتلقون
علاجهم في مستشفيات في ولايه الحوض الشرقي
الموريتانيه على الحدود مع مالي
اعلن وزير الخارجيه الامريكي انتن بلنكن
عزم واشنطن دعم تحويل الهدنه الحاليه في
اليمن الى اتفاق على وقف شامل ودائما
للقتال وقال المتحدث باسم الخارجيه
الامريكيه ماثيوم ان الوزير بلنكن اكد
خلال لقائه في نيويورك رئيس مجلس القياده
اليمني رشاد العليمي على هامش اعمال
الجمعيه العامه للامم المتحده على ضروره
البدء في عمليه سياسيه يمنيه تشمل الجميع
وتحتا مظله الامم المتحده
[موسيقى]
في الحصاد وفي العناوين
فرق الانقاذ تواصلوا البحث عن المفقودين
جراء السيول درنا الليبيه السلطات تعلن
تضرر نحو 70% من البنيه التحتيه وتؤكد انه
لا داعي للخوف بشان انتشار الاوبئه في
المدينه والمبعوث الامم يقول للجزيره ان
حجم الكارثه غير مسبوق في تاريخ البلاد
وفي المغرب استمرار جهود اغاثه المنكوبين
من زلزال الحوز استئناف الدراسه في
المناطق المتضرره تدريجيا بدءا من اليوم
وبدء حصر للمنازل المنهاره لدعم اصحابها
ماليه
[موسيقى]
صفقه تبادل سجناء بين ايران والولايات
المتحده بوساطه قطريه خمسه امريكيين
وافراد اسرهم يصلون الدوحه
وايرانيان يصلان طهران قادمين من الدوحه
بعد اخراج الولايات المتحده عنهما رئيس
الوزراء القطري يقول ان بلاده تامل ان
يمهد الاتفاق لمزيد من التفاهمات وبايدن
يثمن
البدايه من تداعيات السيول في شرق ليبيا
مش مستوعبين الموضوع
[موسيقى]
تتواصل جهود اجهزه الاسعاف الليبيه
بمسانده فرق اجنبيه للبحث عن المفقودين
وجثث الضحايا جراء السيول في درنه شرقي
ليبيا وقال الهلال الاحمر الليبي ان فرق
الانقاذ تواجه تحديات كبيره في عمليات
انتشال جثث الضحايا من البحر ونشد ناشطون
ميدانيون دول العالم الاسراعي بتقديم دعم
لوجستيه للبحث عن الضحايا التفاصيل في هذا
التقرير
دارنا المدينه المنكوبه تنوء تحت حمل ثقيل
مسؤولون صحيون يحذرون من ان الامال في
العثور على ناجينا تتضاءل لكن فرق الانقاذ
تواصل جهودها لانتشال الاحياء اينما وجدوا
كل هذه الجهود لا تزال قاصره عن الاقتراب
من طي صفحه الاستجابه الاولى للكارثه
فالوضع مفشع والفرق المختصه غير كافيه
للاحاطه بحجم الفاجعه
نطالب العالم انهم
محتاجين الاضواء للغداره احنا نطالب
العالم انهم فنيين وتقنين اللي تحت الركام
واللي في البحر
لا يزال التحدي الاقصى في درنه انتشال جثث
الضحايا من البحر
[موسيقى]
صعبه شويه يعني التعامل معها
المتطورين بعمليه مسح على الشواطي ولو كان
في موجود اي جثه الهلال
تواجه الصعوبات في التعامل مع الجثث لغياب
التقنيات الاساسيه لكن الحياه دوما ما
تكون اقوى فالهلال الاحمر الليبي اكد انه
انتشل سيدتين على قيد الحياه بعد مرور
قرابه اسبوع على الكارثه فما العوامل التي
تسهم في نجاه العالقين تحت الانقاض في
الكوارث الطبيعيه
الوصول الى المياه عامل اساسي تشير
تقديرات الى ان المده التي يمكن للانسان
ان يبقى فيها حيا دون ماء تراوح بين ثلاثه
ايام وسبعه ايام مع الاخذ بعين الاعتبار
درجات الحراره وبالتالي كميه السوائل التي
يفقدها جسم الانسان الوصول الى الهواء
اساسي ايضا وذلك يعتمد على البقعه التي
علق بها الشخص سواء تتيح ممرا للهواء او
كانت مغلقه لتفادي
عدم وجود اصابات يساعد بدوره في استدامه
الحياه
وغياب حطام ثقيل فوق جسم الشخص العالق
عامل مهم ايضا يبقى ان توفر الطعام يزيد
من فرص النجاه يمكن الاستمرار دونه اسابيع
لكن بالنسبه الى الغالبيه العظمى قد تقتصر
المهله على بضعه ايام كما يلعب عمر
الانسان دورا في البقاء على قيد الحياه
لفتره اطول وتزيد هذه المده بغياب امراض
مزمنه
وانضم الان الينا من درن مراسلنا تامر
الصمادي اهلا بك من جديد تامر تامر هل من
اصداء لما اعلنته السلطات عن تضرر 70% من
المدينه بسبب ما جرى وايضا ليس هناك اي
خوف من انتشار الاوبئه
من خلال مشاهداتك انت ماذا تستطيع ان تقول
لنا
اما ليله هذه النسبه التي قدمتها السلطات
بالمناسبه قد تكون قليله لان غالبيه
المدينه بات مدمرا نحن نتنقل من مكان الى
اخر في كل يوم في كل ساعه لا سيما في عمق
المدينه وفي المناطق الاكثر تضررا وهي
المناطق الشرقيه الدمار كبير هائل هذه
المدينه ليست منكوبه فحسب ان كان هنالك
يعني وصف اخر اكثر صعوبه قد يكون هو ذلك
لان
الركام في كل مكان مباني كثيره اقتلعت من
اصلها طرقات كثيره احياء كثيره باتت اثرا
بعد عين هذه المباني التي نشاهدها في كل
ساعه في كل لحظه اقتلعت وذهبت كسرا باتجاه
البحر الوضع كارثي كارثي بكل ما تعنيه
الكلمه من معنى لا نبالغ ليله انت قلت
بانه يعني هذه المره الاولى التي اشاهد
فيها مثل هذه
المحققه والكبيره هنا في مدينه درنه
لاسيما كما قلت في المناطق الشرقيه تحديدا
الحديث عن وادا درنه يعني
المناطق التي باتت مقطعه الاوصال هناك
بالمناسبه ونحن في اليوم الثامن ونقترب من
التاسع على تلك الفيضانات المدمر المدمره
هنالك اماكن حتى هذه اللحظه لم يتمكن او
تتمكن فرق الانقاذ من الوصول اليها هنالك
شح كبير في فرق الانقاذ مع يعني رغم وصول
العديد من الفرق العربيه والاجنبيه لان
السلطات والمنظمات الاغاثيه المحليه لا
سيما الصليب الاحمر الليبي هنا في المدينه
الجميع يواصل المناشده وتقديم وطلب العون
من دول العالم لان الكارثه كبيره والفرق
التي تاتي لا سيما الفرق المحليه التي
تاتي من الشرق ومن الغرب غير مزوده
بالامكانيات سنتحدث عن امك جدا بدائيه
والمخاوف نهايه الليله من انتشار الاوبئه
هو هي مخاوف متكرره تصدر على لسان العديد
من المسؤولين الصحيين وهو ما دفع السلطات
خلال الساعات الماضيه الى تقسيم المدينه
الى ثلاثه اقسام خطره وهشه وغير قابله
للحياه وهو ايضا ما دفع السلطات خلال
الساعات الاخيره ايضا الى التلويح بخيار
الاخلاء اخلاء عديد المناطق ربما نشهد ذلك
خلال الساعات المقبله تامر الصمادي من
درنه شكرا لك كذلك
ينضم الينا من درنا عمر الطبال قائد فرقه
الاغاثه والدعم الانساني في جمعيه بيوت
الشباب الليبيه
سيد عمر طبعا الوضع ماساوي بكل المعايير
وذلك وفق جهات مختلفه انتم في جمعيه بيوت
الشباب الليبيه
ما الذي تواجهونه من تحديات في جهود
اغاثتكم
نعم في البدايه مساء الخير وعليكم وعلى كل
المشاهدين قناه الجزيره
فريق الاسناد الايوائي ولغاتي والدعم
النفسي لجمعيه بيوت الشباب الليبيه الذي
يتمركز على طرفي المدينه منذ ساعات الاولى
لهذه الكارثه
يواجه لربما عديد التحديات كغيره من الفرق
الموجوده في عين الحدث منها توفير
توفير الاغاثه اللازمه لكافه اهالي
المدينه نظرا لما تعانيه هذه المدينه من
شح كبير جدا في الموارد بمخت مساهم كذلك
نوجه تحديات في الحفاظ على افراد ومنتسبي
حركه بيوت الشباب الليبيه الموجودين في
عين الحدث الذين يقدر عددهم باكثر من 150
فرد الحفاظ على صحه هؤلاء الاشخاص
وسلامتهم هو من اهم الاولويات كذلك خاصه
في ظلمه نسمعه عن الخوف من انتشار عديد
الامراض التي تتبع مثل هذه الكوارث
والمتعارف عليها في العالم كما اننا نواجه
تحديات في ايواء الاسر
لربما من اهم اولويات هذه المؤسسه هو
توفير الايواء الامن للاسر التي تضررت من
هذه
الحادثه كما اننا نحاول العمل على جانب
مهم جدا لربما لم لم نلاحظ فيه خطوات
كبيره حتى هذه اللحظه ونحن نقترب من تاسع
ايام هذه الكارثه هو جانب الاسناد النفسي
والدعم النفسي
للاسره التي تضررت بشكل بشكل كبير فلربما
هي هذه ابرز التحديات التي تواجهنا حتى
هذه اللحظه الحديث عن تضرر سبعين بالمئه
من البنيه التحتيه
الى اي حد فعلا هذا يحدد القرار او يسهم
في اتخاذ قرار باجلاء المدينه من السكان
ومن بقي من السكان على قيد الحياه في ظل
هذه الظروف
الصعبه للغايه
حقيقه
لربما لا نمتلك حتى هذه اللحظه كفريق
اسناد واغاثه ودعم نفسي لحركه بيوت الشباب
الليبيه اي ارقام محدده بشان او نسب بشان
البنيه البنيه التحتيه
وتهلكها ولكننا الحقيقه
كافراد نشتغل من من عين الحدث نلاحظ دمار
كبير جدا في في هذه في هذه المدينه
ولكننا حقيقه نعمل على حاليا على ترتيب
الاوضاع بشكل يمكن او يضمن للاسر التي
التي تتواجد الان
البقاء والعيش بشكل بشكل سليم وفي اطار
نفسي كما ذكرت يكون العامل النفسي فيه مهم
جدا
ولكننا حقيقه نترك هذا الجانب الى جهات
جهات مختصه اشكرك عمر الطبال قائد فرقه
الاغاثه والدعم الانساني في جمعيه بيوت
الشباب الليبيه
معنا الان من مدينه شحات وزير الموارد
المائيه في الحكومه الليبيه المكلفه من
البرلمان محمد دومه اهلا بك سيد وزير في
الواقع اسالك سؤال ربما طرحه المبعوث
الاممي عبد الله بتيلي عندما قال هل كان
بالامكان تجنب ما حدث وانتم مسؤولون عن
وضع السدود في درنا وفي غيرها من مدن
الشرق
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم والصلاه والسلام
على اشرف الانبياء والمرسلون الحقيقه اختي
الكريمه هذا السؤال يعني يحتاج الى عمليه
تحقيق وعمليه تقييم كامله لما حدث طبعا في
البدايه لابد ان ننوه ان كميات الامطار
التي سقطت يعني سقطت بارقام قياسيه ليست
على مستوى حوض البحر المتوسط وانما على
مستوى العالم يعني كميات الامطار التي
نزلت في فتره وجيزه جدا او التي عطلت في
فتره وجيزه جدا كانت كبيره جدا وكانت يعني
خارج مستوى التوقعات رغم حتى
محاولتنا في لجنه الطوارئ
توجيه الاسئله لخبراء الارصاد والمركز
الليبي للارصاد في طرابلس يعني لم يتوقع
احد حقيقه سقوط هذه الكميات الكبيره من
النظار ولكن هذا لا يعني ولكن هذا لا يعني
انا ساؤمن اختي الكريم ولكن هذا لا يعني
ان نحن
بسبب ابتسامات السياسيه
الظروف السياسيه المعروفه في البلاد من
حوالي 12 سنه
ان توقفت عمليه الصيانه السدود وتوقفت حتى
عمليه مراقبه هذه السدود بشكل صحيح طبعا
نحن كحكومه ليبيه مكلفه من البرلمان نخلي
مسؤولياتنا تماما لان حاولنا مخاطبه حتى
المسؤولين على هؤلاء السدود طبعا الاداره
السجود كانت موجوده في وزاره الموارد
المائيه التابعه
لحكومه لحكومه الوحده الوطنيه الموجوده في
طرابلس والتي يعني رفضت التسليم الحكومه
الليبيه الاداره يعني
بياناتها وبكامل قاعده البيانات المتعلقه
بها موجوده في طرابلس وكذلك موظفين السدود
في المنطقه يطلعون هذه الاداره
والاشراف المباشر عليهم من تلك الاداره
حاولنا التواصل معهم حاولنا مساعدتهم خلال
الفتره البسيطه اللي استلمت فيها الحكومه
ويعني خاطبناهم بشكل مباشر عن حاجتهم اذا
كانوا
يبدو هل انقطع الاتصال
للاسف يبدو ان الاتصال قد انقطع محمد دومه
وزير الموارد المائيه في الحكومه
الليبيه
المكلفه من البرلمان للاسف كنا نتمنى ان
نواصل
الحوار معه لا ادري السيد محمد دومه سيد
وزير تسمعني الان
للاسف للاسف سنحاول على العموم معاوده
الاتصال ولكن الان ينضم الي من طرابلس
مراسلنا احمد خليفه احمد اذا مهم جدا ان
نعرف منك اخر المعلومات بشان ما تقوله
السلطات
بالنسبه للوضع في الشرق الليبي تفضل
اخر تطور ليلى منذ قليل اعدنت شركه الخدمه
العامه
وبطبيعه الحال لديها فرق في مدينه درنه
عامله هناك اعلنت ان هذه الفرق انتشرت ست
جثث من ضحايا السيول من مواقع مختلفه في
مدينه درنان قبل ذلك وفي المؤتمر الصحفي
اليومي اليوم اعلن محمد حموده الناطق
الرسمي باسم الحكومه ان هيئه التعرف على
المفقودين انتشرت حوالي 30 جثه وان جهاز
المباحث العامه انتشل قرابه 20 جثه
وبالتالي يكون العدد يقترب من 60 جثه التي
انتشرت اليوم
ومع تقدم الايام والطول المده ليله تتضاءى
الفرص العثور على احياء ويبدو ان الجهود
الان اصبحت منصبه بالكامل على عمليه البحث
عن الجثث بين الركام والبيوت المهدمه
والبيوت والمناطق التي غمرتها السيول الى
جانب الجثث الموجوده في البحر وهي كما
تقول المصادر من هناك عددها كبير جدا
وخصوصا العائلات التي
جرفتها السيول وهي تحاول الهرب بالسيارات
في اثناء حدوث السيول في مدينه درنه
منذ حوالي اكثر من ساعه ليله انتهى
المؤتمر الصحفي للفريق الحكومي هنا في
العاصمه طرابلس وهو وهو مؤتمر يومي سبق
لعبد الحميد البيبه وان ذكر الجزيره انه
يبني قراراته على المعلومات الوارده اليه
من هذا الفريق هذا الفريق اليوم عندنا عن
بعض الاجراءات المتعلقه بعمل الفرق الفنيه
والحكوميه في مدينه درنه منها على سبيل
المثال استمرار عمل الشركه العامه
للكهرباء هناك
وانها تمكنت من اعاده شبكه الكهرباء الى
اجزاء واسعه من مدينه درنه ومنذ قليل
اعلنت الشركه على صفحتها الرسميه وصول
محطه كهرباء مجروره الى منطقه شيحه في
مدينه درنه ايضا كان هناك احد المتحدثين
في المؤتمر الصحفي وهو
التعليم والتربيه الذي قال ان هذه السيول
والفيضانات دمرت عددا من المدارس واصابه
مدارس اخرى باضرار مختلفه وان العدد الكلي
الاضرار التي اصابت المدارس في منطقه
الجبل الاخضر حوالي 114 واربعه عشره مدرسه
تفاوتت اضرارها بين التي دمرت بالكامل
وبين التي لحقتها
اضرار طفيفه شكرا جزيلا لك احمد خليفه على
هذه المعلومات من طرابلس
[موسيقى]
الان الى مستجدات الزلزال في المغرب
تتواصل جهود الانقاذ والاغاثه لمجابهه
التداعيات زلزال الحوز تستمر عمليات البحث
عن ناجين وانتشار جثث الضحايا لليوم
الحادي عشر على التواليت منذ وقوع الزلزال
كما اعلنت السلطات المغربيه مواصله عمليات
فتح الطرق الجبليه المؤديه الى القرى
النائيه المتضرره من الزلزال وقال رئيس
الحكومه المغربيه عزيز اخنوش ان تاهيل
المناطق المتضرره سياخذ في الاعتبار تقويه
البنيه التحتيه والرفعه من جوده الخدمات
العموميه وفي الاثناء تواصل الهيئه
الاغاثيه جهودها لايواء المنكوبين وعلاج
الجرحى
كل ذلك مع بدء تفعيل البرنامج الحكومي
الطارئ لايواء من فقدوا منازلهم
وكانت الحكومه المغربيه اعلنت استئناف
الدراسه اليوم في الاقاليم الخمسه التي
ضربها زلزال الحوس وقد حضر العديد من
الطلبه الى خيام تم تجهيزها كمدارس مؤقته
في حين نقل عدد اخر من الطلبه من منطقه
ثلاث اليعقوب ومناطق اخرى الى مدينه مراكش
بعد تعذر انشاء مدارس هناك
[موسيقى]
بعد عشره ايام على وقوع زلزال الحوز قررت
الحكومه المغربيه استئناف العمليه
التعليميه في المناطق المتضرره اكثر من
500 وحده تعليميه كانت عامله في تلك
المنطقه
استبدل جزء كبير منها مؤقتا بالخيام اليوم
تم استقبال الطلاب والطالبات وكانوا
الحضور متميز فقد 80 في المئه وكل الاطر
التربوي الاداريه حاضره في المؤسسه
لاستقبال للطلاب بالطبع كانت كان كان
الدخول
كان التركيز فيه على جانب الوجدان النفسي
من اجل العوده
لعجله الحياه بشكل تدريجي
هذه احدى مدارس اطفال المرحله الابتدائيه
هنا في امزمز
كان لابد من تعريف الاطفال بما حدث وشرح
اسباب عدم عودتهم الى مقاعدهم القديمه
السلطات الى تجاوز صدمه الزلزال واثاره
ولعل الاعلان عن عوده الدراسه في المناطق
التي ضربها الزلزال مؤشر على هذا السعيد
لكن الامر لا يخلو من صعوبات
نتوجه الى احدى القرى النائيه في منطقه
جاط في اقليم شيشاوه
خلف هؤلاء عدل
الفاقه التي زادها الزلزال كانت سببا لعدم
قدره بعضهم على الذهاب الى المدرسه
وللبعض اسباب اخرى
طيب مدارس اليوم بدات
المشققين
باقي خايف
طلبوا الامر وقتا ليعتاد التلاميذ مدارسهم
الجديده
خاصه اولئك الذين غيب الموت بعض زملائهم
ترى الحكومه ان المهم الان هو ان لا
ينقطعوا عن الدراسه
فاولويه التعليم لا تقل اهميه عن مهمه
الايواء عمر الحاجه الجزيره من بدله
امزميز جنوب مراكش
سبحان الله عيون الاطفال في هذا التقرير
تحكي القصه كلها على العموم انضم الان
الينا مراسلنا المختار العلاوي المختار
كنت في الساعه الاولى في اسني الان انت في
تحناوت في اقليم الحوز ضعنا في صوره ايضا
محاولات اعاده الحياه الى طبيعتها على
الاقل بالنسبه للتلاميذ
بالفعل ليله تدريجيا مظاهر الحياه بدات
تعود الى طبيعتها ومن ذلك توجه التلاميذ
كيفما كانوا الى المؤسسات التعليميه هذا
التوجه ليس طبيعيا كبقيه المناطق المغرب
هنا بفعل الزلزال وبفعل تداعياته توجه
التلاميذ الى المدارس والمدارس كانت عباره
عن خيام وضعتها سلطات المغربيه خاصه وزاره
التعليم من اجل نقل التلاميذ من تلك
المباني المدمره ذلك الوسط الذي فيه
بنايات مدمره الان بدات الفكره ان ننقلهم
الى خيم خيم يعني حتى يبتعد ذهنيا تلك
تبتعد تلك المشاهد عن هؤلاء الاطفال على
الاقل خلال ساعات الدوام وخلال ساعات
الدراسه هذه هي الجزئيه الاولى التي ساعدت
وزاره التعليم المغربيه الى نقلها اولئك
التلاميذ هذا هذا الامر تم عن طريق ثلاثه
مستويات المستوى الاول هو نقل مؤسسات
تعليميه كلها بما في ذلك التلاميذ
الاساتذه الاطر الاداريه كما وقع في اغليل
مركز الزلزال وايضا مراكز اخرى ضربها
زلزال بقوه تم نقل تلك المؤسسات الى مناطق
امنه وبدات العمليه الدراسيه اليوم لكننا
لاحظنا خصوصا على مستوى الفتيات ان الصدمه
لا تزال بادعه على هؤلاء الفتيات اللواتي
بدانا الدراسه اليوم وفي الحقيقه كما قلت
سابقا لم تكن هناك دراسه بقدر ما كانت
جلسات للحوار للتخفيف عن هؤلاء الطالبات
اللواتي غادرن منازلهن وغادر منازلناهن
المدمره وغادرنا عائلاتهم الجزئيه الثانيه
هي الخيام والجزئيه الثالثه هي الاقسام
المتنقله الذي بدات التي بدا وضعها
تدريجيا في المناطق المتضرره في مستوى اخر
كانت هناك اليوم بدات فرق تقنيه تخرج الى
الشوارع المناطق المتضرره لمعاينه المنازل
المتضرره هل هي منازل متضرره يجب هدمها
نهائيا ام منازل متضرره بالامكان القيام
بعمليه تدعيم لها وبالتالي سوف تبقى صالحه
للسكن هذه اللجانه التقنيه التي خرجت الان
ربما تقريبا في حدود اسبوعين من الان يجب
عليها ان تنهي له خمسين الف منزل لتبدا
المرحله الثانيه وهي تقديم الدعم المادي
واكيد يحمل كثير من الفرحه لكثير من
المتضررين شكرا جزيلا المختار العلاوي من
تحناوت في اقليم الحوس
[موسيقى]
وصل الى العاصمه القطريه سجناء الامريكيون
الخمسه الذين كانوا محتجزين في ايران
تنفيذا لصفقه تبادل سجناء بين الولايات
المتحده وايران بوساطه قطريه قد وصل
المفرج عنهم الى مطار الدوحه الدولي على
متن طائره تابعه لخطوط الجويه القطريه
وتتضمن صفقه التبادل ايضا الافراج عن خمسه
سجناء ايرانيين في الولايات المتحده
بالاضافه الى وصول اموال ايرانيه مفرج
عنها من كوريا الجنوبيه الى حسابات
ايرانيه مسجله في مصرفين قطريين
رحله الطائره القطريه القادمه من طهران
الى الدوحه استغرقت حوالي ساعتين لكنها
تطلبت نحو عامين من جوالات تفاوض خاضتها
الوساطه القطريه كان خمسه امريكيين واسرهم
على متن طائره الخطوط القطريه وكان في
استقبالهم مسؤولون قطريون وامريكيون في
مطار الدوحه الدولي
الدبلوماسيه القطريه بهذه الخطوه نجحت في
تخفيف حته التوتر بين واشنطن وطهران اذ ان
تنفيذ تبادل السجناء فتح المجال امام
المضي في مزيد من التفاهمات والعوده الى
خطه العمل المشتركه وحلحلت العديد من
الملفات الشائكه بين الطرفين الاتفاق تضمن
ايضا تحويل اموال ايرانيه الى حسابات
مصرفيه في الدوحه بلغت 6 مليارات دولار
ستشرف عليها دوله قطر الاتفاق تضمن العديد
من الضمانات فيما يتعلق خاصه باعداد حيث
تم الاتفاق على تفعيل هذه القناه المصرفيه
الانسانيه من
لصالح تحديدا المواد الغذائيه والادويه
والاجهزه الطبيه والمنتجات الزراعيه بما
يضمن ان يتم استخدام هذه الاموال حصرا في
الجانب الانساني وفيما يعود بالنفع طبعا
على مواطنيه الجمهوريه الاسلاميه وهذا هو
الامر طبعا الذي تم التوقف عليه بين
الطرفين ووفق ما ذهبت اليه الخارجيه
القطريه فان هذا الاتفاق ليس نهايه بذاتها
بقدر ما يفتح افاقا لتناول ملفات كثيره
اخرى تتطلب نفس المثابره الدبلوماسيه
مستقبلا اتمام صفقه تبادل السجناء بين
واشنطن وطهران وتحويل سته مليارات دولار
من الاموال الايرانيه المجمده الى حسابات
مصرفيه في الدوحه ثمره لوساطه قطر التي
استطاعت من خلالها تقريب وجهات النظر بين
ايران وامريكا وفتح قنوات اتصال ساهمت في
تدليل كثير من العقبات بين الجانبين
سار رشيد الجزيره الدوحه
وكاله الانباء الايرانيه فادت بوصول اثنين
من السجناء الايرانيين المفرج عنهم الى
طهران قادمين من الدوحه وفقا لاتفاق
التبادل الامريكي الايراني بواسطه قطريه
حتى الطائره القطريه في طهران كانت تقل
على متنها كلا من بغداد معين انصاري ورضا
سرهانك الذين اختار العوده الى بلدهما وفق
ارادتهما بحسب الخارجيه الايرانيه
هذا وقال رئيس الوزراء وزير الخارجيه
القطريه شيخ محمد بن عبد الرحمن الثاني
انه يامل ان يمهد الاتفاق الامريكي
الايراني بشان تبادل السجناء لمزيد من
التفاهمات واضاف في منشور على منصه اكس
انه يتوجه بالشكر لطرفي الاتفاق ولشركاء
قطر الذين ساهموا في انجاحه لا سيما سلطنه
عمان واكد رئيس الوزراء وزير الخارجيه
القطري ان قطر مستمره في المساهمه في كل
ما من شانه تعزيز امن المنطقه والعالم
هذا وكان وزير الدوله في وزاره الخارجيه
القطريه محمد الخليفه قال ان الاتفاق بدا
بالافراج عن سجناء من البلدين وتحويل
اموال ايرانيه الى حسابات مصرفيه في
الدوحه وكذلك في تصريح لوكاله الانباء ان
تنفيذ هذا الاتفاق دلاله على مكانه دوله
قطر كشريك دولي موثوق به في مجال الوساطه
واثقه الاطراف كافه في نزاهتها وحياتها
كما اعرب الخليفي عن امل قطر في ان يفضي
التنفيذ الكامل للاتفاق بين الولايات
المتحده وايران الى تفاهمات اكبر تشمل
العوده الى خطه العمل الشامله المشتركه
ومن جانبه ثمنا الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
صفقه التبادل وقال انها ستعيد اخيرا خمسه
امريكيين كانوا مسجونين في ايران الى
وطنهم وقال وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه ان
اتفاق تبادل السجناء مع ايران منفصل عن
القضايا الاخرى مع طهران بما في ذلك قضيه
احياء الاتفاق النووي كما اشار بلنكا في
مؤتمر الصحفيين في نيويورك الى ان تركيز
بلادهم صب على اعاده المواطنين الامريكيين
المحتجزين في ايران
دعوني اكون واضحا للغايه ان هذه العمليه
والمحادثات الخاصه باطلاق سراح الامريكيين
كان دائما في مسار منفصل عن القضايا
الاخرى وبغض النظر عما يحدث وفي الجهود
الراميه الى العوده للاتفاق النووي فقد
ركزنا على العمل بشكل مستقل على اعاده
الامريكيين الى بلادهم وهذا لا يعني اي
شيء في علاقاتنا مع ايران وما زلنا مصممين
على اتخاذ اي خطوات ضروريه لمعالجه تصرفات
ايران في مختلف المجالات وفي نفس الوقت لا
نزال نعتقد ان الدبلوماسيه هي افضل طريقه
للوصول الى نتيجه فعاله بخصوص البرنامج
النووي الايراني
اما الرئيس الايراني ابراهيم رئيسي فقال
ان اطلاق سراح الامريكيين الخمسه مزدوجيه
الجنسيه كان عملا انسانيا بحثا واضاف رئيس
يعقبه وصوله نيويورك لحضور الجمعيه العامه
للامم المتحده انا من الممكن القيام
باجراءات انسانيه اخرى في المستقبل بين
طهران وواشنطن
وبدورها ثمنت وزاره الخرجه الايرانيه دور
دوله قطر المؤثر في عمليه انتقال اصول
ماليه ايرانيه وتبادل السجناء مع واشنطن
ووجهت الشكر لسلطنه عمان وسويسرا على
جهودهما وقالت الخارجيه الايرانيه في بيان
انفاق الاموال المحرره في قطر سيتم بناء
على احتياجات ايران واولوياتها
بعد كثير من تراكمات الخطاب العدائي بين
ايران والولايات المتحده الامريكيه ورغم
الثقه المفقوده بين الجانبين وكثره
الملفات الشائكه لم يعدم البلدان النفاذ
من اضيق الابواب الى تفاهمات عبر الحوار
تجعل الصعب ممكنا وما كان للحوار ان يتم
لولا دبلوماسيه قطريه منحها الطرفان
ثقتهما وكان من نتائجها ما شهدته الدوحه
من وصول خمسه سجناء امريكيين قادمين من
طهران الى قطر للذهاب من بعد الى الولايات
المتحده
ويشكل الافراج عن السجناء الامريكيين
مقابل خمسه سجناء ايرانيين من السجون
الامريكيه تتويا لحوارات طويله توسطت فيها
قطر الطائره التي جاءت بالامريكيين الخمسه
الى الدوحه ستقل ثلاثه من السجناء
الايرانيين المحررين الى بلادهم بعد ان
تخلف منهم اثنان مؤثرين التوجه الى بلد
اخر قطر التي حصدت ثمره جهودها قال الرئيس
وزرائها ووزير خارجيتها الشيخ محمد بن عبد
الرحمن ال ثاني ان بلاده مستمره في كل ما
من شانه تعزيز امن المنطقه والعالم ولا
يقف الاتفاق بين الجانبين عند تبادل
السجناء بل يضمك جزء منه فك الحظر المفروض
على اموال ايرانيه تبلغ نحو سته مليارات
دولار
وقد تم بالفعل وفقا لافادات المسؤولين
القطريين والايرانيين ايداع هذه الاموال
في بنوك قطريه تحت ما تسميه واشنطن
بالقناه الانسانيه التي تمكن الايرانيين
من السحب منها لاغراض انسانيه فقط
وحذرت الولايات المتحده من انه في حال
خروج الصرف عن هذه الاغراض وهي مما يتصل
بحاجه ايران الى المواد الغذائيه
والدوائيه والزراعيه فان واشنطن ستعود الى
فرض التجميل على الحسابات
وايما كانت العقبات التي قد تنشا في تعريف
ما هو انساني فان الاتفاق يمثل اختراقا
كبيرا للدبلوماسيه في كسر جمود العلاقه
الايرانيه الامريكيه مع ضخامه رصيدها من
سوء الظن ومن التربص فما اكثر ما وقف
البلدان على حافه المواجهه في مياه الخليج
والمواجهه العسكريه هي ما تحرض عليه
اسرائيل امريكا للقضاء على برنامج ايران
النووي وكانت اسرائيل قد رفضت الصفقه التي
تمت بين الولايات المتحده وايران زعمه
انها تشكل دعما لما تسميه اسرائيل الارهاب
الايراني وتعزيزا لقدرات طهران وهو امر
سيكون بمثابه تراجع خطير عن استراتيجيه
الاحتواء الامريكي بحسب اسرائيل الغضب
الاسرائيلي الذي فشل في تعطيل الصفقه كشف
عن تقاطع للمصالح الامريكيه الاسرائيليه
ربما لمره بهذا الوضوح من جانب اخر بدت
الصفقه التي سعت فيها قطر بيانا في
امكانيه الذهاب ابعد الى مقاربه القضيه
الاكثر تعقيدا وهي ملف ايران النووي الذي
بقي منذ خروج واشنطن منه على عهد الرئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب سببا لتعزيم العلاقه
مع واشنطن والغرب تاره ومع الوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه الذريه الذراع الفني للقوه
العظمى لحراست نادي الدول النوويه ما يدخل
عليها داخل الا عنوه واقتدارا صنع الهند
وباكستان وكوريا الشماليه
[موسيقى]
واذا كانت الدبلوماسيه القطريه ستجد دفعا
وتحفيزا بما حققت من نجاح في صفقه تحرير
الانفس والاموال فان ايران ايضا ربما وجدت
السبيل الدبلوماسيه اكثر جدوى واعجل فائده
انه براح يوفر طاقتها في السياسه وفي
الاقتصاد ويجعل ما يبدو مستحيلا امرا
ممكنا
طبعا التصريحات التي تابعناها للتو بشان
هذه الصفقه سواء من جانب وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه او من جانب الرئيس الايراني
كانت تاتي من نيويورك التي قصدها قاده
العالم
عدد كبير من القاده من اجل الحضور اجتماع
الجمعيه العامه للامم المتحده في نيويورك
والزميلتنا العزيزه خديجه بن قنه موجوده
كذلك في نيويورك لمتابعه وقاعده وقائع هذا
الاجتماع خديجه معنا الان
مباشره من نيويورك تفضلي خديجه
ليلى
ومشاهدينا اهلا وسهلا بكم شكرا ليلى وكما
تشاهدين ليلى في هذه الاجواء الماطره وتحت
هذه السماء الرماديه ومن ورائنا تبدا او
تنطلق او انطلقت اعمال قمه اهداف التنميه
المستدامه بمقر الامم المتحده حيث نتواجد
الان في مدينتي نيويورك طبعا هذه قمه
اهداف التنميه المستدامه كما قلت بدات
بمقر الامم المتحده في نيويورك واعتمدت
الدول الاعضاء اعلانا سياسيا لتسريع
القضاء على المشاكل المتعلقه بالتنميه
المستدامه اذا كما قلت تبنت الجمعيه
العامه للامم المتحده مشروع الاعلان
السياسي بشان اهداف التنميه المستدامه
الذي يجدد الالتزام بتلك الاهداف ويعيد
احياء الامل من جديد نح تحقيقها بحلول عام
2030 وبحسب نص المشروع فان خطه عام 2030
تظل خارطه الطريق الشامله لتحقيق التنميه
المستدامه والتغلب طبعا على الازمات
المتعدده التي يواجهها العالم كما يؤكد
ايضا المشروع التزام قاده العالم
بتنفيذ الفعال لخطه عام 2030 واهداف
التنميه المستدامه تبنت الجمعيه العامه
للامم المتحده مشروع الاعلان السياسي بشان
كل ما ذكرته قبل قليل اضافه الى الالتزام
باتخاذ اجراءات مستمره وجوهريه وعاجله
للتغلب على الازمات المتعدده التي واجه
العالم كما يؤكد المشروع التزام قاده
العالم بتنفيذ الفعالي خطه عمل 2030 ودعى
نص المشروع الى تحسين اليات الديون
الدوليه لدعم مراجعه الديون وتعليق سدادها
واعاده هيكله
هيكلتها حسب الحاجه الان ينضم الينا من
مقر الامم المتحده مراسل الجزيره احمد
هزيم احمد اذا كما ذكرنا
تمخضت اعمال اليوم عن اعلان سياسي دعنا في
صوره هذا الاعلام
نعم خديجه هذا الاعلان السياسي كما تحدث
عنه الامين العامري
الامم المتحده انطونيو
ركز على دفع الدول الاعضاء الى اعاده
الالتزام بما التزمت به عام 2015 عندما تم
الاعلان عن هذه الاهداف اهداف التنميه
المستدربه وهي سبعه عشر هدفا يراد منها سد
الفجوه عبر تكامل في برامج التنميه بين
الدول الاكثر غنى والدول الاكثر فقرا لرفع
مستوى بعض من الخدمات التي تعتبر اساسيه
لخلق تنميه مستدامه ينتفع منها الجميع
الامين العام كان ممتعضا من ان السعي او
الجهود لتحقيق هذه الاهداف عام 2030 بعد
سبعه اعوام من الان لا تزال دون المستوى
15% فقط من تلك الاهداف يتم المسار فيها
بشكل صحيح حسب ما قال الامين العام وبعضها
تلك الاهداف المسار كما قال معاكس ان هناك
انحصار
بالجهود لتحقيق هذه الاهداف ودعا الى دع
الدول الاعضاء الى اعاده التاكيد على
التزامها واعاده تخصيص بعض من جهودها
لتحقيق هذه الاهداف البيان السياسي يؤكد
على هذا الخليج بين السياسي يعيد التاكيد
على الاهداف السبعه عشر وعلى ضروره فتح
المجال امام الدول الفقيره للوصول الى
التمويل اللازم لانشاء هذه المشاريع
مشاريع التنميه المستدامه وتحدث ايضا
الامين العام من انه من العار على العالم
في ظل الثروه المتراكمه حاليا خصوصا في
بعض الدول الغنيه ان يكون الجوع لا يزال
مشكله تعاني منها بعض الدول وتعاني من بعض
منها بعض المجتمعات خديجه
نعم شكرا جزيلا لك احمد هزيم من مقر الامم
المتحده وتبدا اليوم الثلاثاء الاجتماعات
رفيعه المستوى لهذه الدوره الثامنه
والسبعين للجمعيه العامه للامم المتحده
وذلك بمشاركه نحو 150 من القاده والرؤساء
والرؤساء الحكومات والوزراء ويتوقع ان
تهيمن الحرب في اوكرانيا على نقاشات
الجمعيه للعام الثاني على التوالي
الامم المتحده امام تحدي وجودي فهي تخسر
شيئا فشيئا فاعليتها في الوقايه من
النزاعات ومنعها وتهدئه القائم منها وتفشل
مره تلوى اخرى في ايجاد الحلول ومواجهه
التحديات والمشكله ليست هنا في الجمعيه
العامه فمصالح الدول جميعا تراعى على حد
سواء والانقسام اقل حده ازاء اغلب القضايا
المشكله في مجلس الامن حيث يحتكر القرار
غالبا لمصلحه قله قويه
خلافات الدول دائمه العضويه تعكس نفسها
على ازمات العالم المنظوره امام المجلس
وبات التوافق متعذرا حتى في جدول الاعمال
ومقدمي الاحاطات
في وقت تطغى فيه القضاء العربيه من فلسطين
والسودان الى سوريا وليبيا ولبنان واليمن
على اجندته وسط تراجع للدوري العربي وقصور
احيانا في تمثيل قضاياه في المجلس
الدول العربيه التي تتمتع بعضويه مجلس
الامن من حقها ان تعبر عن مواقفها الوطنيه
ولكن ايضا
باعتبارها هي تمثل العرب في مجلس الامن
فهي تستند دائما الى قرارات الجامعه
العربيه في كل الموضوعات التي يبحثها مجلس
الامن اصلاحه مجلس الامن حاضر في الاقوال
وليس في الافعال وكورقه احيانا في لعبه
الاستقطابات وخاصه لمغازله افريقيا التي
تطالب مقعد دائما في مجلس تدفع منذ سنوات
بقضاياها بعيدا عنه لمعالجتها عبر
منظماتها الاقليميه التي تكاد مع غيرها من
التكتلات ترث دور المجلس
من المهم ان نتذكر انه لا توجد منظمه
يمكنها التعامل مع هذه التحديات بمفردها
وتطوير هذه الشراكه بين الدول الاعضاء
سيسهم في ايجاد حلول فعاله التجاذبات
امتدت الى العمليات الانسانيه للمنظمه في
مناطق عده في وقت اتسع فيه نطاق الازمات
وتحتاج المنظمه لاغاثه
230 مليون محتاج الى خمسه وخمسين بليون
دولار وتواجه خطط الاستجابه الانسانيه
نقصا كبيرا في التمويل وتقليصا حادا
للبرامج
عمليات حفظ السلام باتت محله تنازع بل
وغير مرغوب في وجوده احيانا فيما غدت مهمه
رصد انتهاكات حقوق الانسان عرضه للتسيس
ناهيك بالمحاسبه عنها فهي غائبه او تطبق
وفقا لمعايير يراها كثيرون مزدوجه نيويورك
وينضم الينا هنا في الامم المتحده من
نيويورك ستيفان ديريك المتحدث باسم الامين
العام للامم المتحده اهلا وسهلا بك
طبعا انت يعني تكون الصندوق الاسود لانه
للامم المتحده لانه هذه دورتك الثالثه
والعشرين في الامم المتحده
في ماذا تختلف هذه الدوره عن باقي الدورات
خديجه في البدايه شكرا على هذه الاستضافه
الكريمه على قناه الجزيره ويسدني ان ارحب
بكم هنا في نيويورك شخصيا نعم بالفعل هي
الدوره الثالثه والعشرين بالنسبه الى
الجمعيه العامه وبين الامور التي لم تتغير
هو شعوري في كل مره اتي فيها الى دور
عندما اعي انه بالفعل من المميز ان نعمل
هنا
ونشهد وقع الدبلوماسيه العالميه وفي كل
عام باستثناء السنه جائحه كورونا قادت
العالم اجتمعوا هنا بجهد بنيه حسنه
لمواجهه التحديات التي يتعين علينا جميعا
ان نحاول ان نحلها من خلال الدبلوماسيه
ومن خلال الحوار ومن خلال التنازلات
نعم
نعم ولكن هذه الدوره تعقل السيد سفندي
جاريك هذه المره في عالم يمر بظروف
استثنائيه حروب انقلابات في دول افريقيه
فيضانات والسيول زلازل مجاعه غياب الامن
الغذائي الحرب الاوكرانيه الروسيه
يعني الكثير من الملفات مطروحه طبعا اي
اضافه الى الملفات التقليديه مثل القضيه
الفلسطينيه هل ترى ان الامم المتحده قادره
اليوم على تقديم حلول لهذه المشاكل
الاجابه القصيره هي نعم
لانه
ما من مؤسسه اخرى يمكننا ان نجلس فيها على
طاوله جميعا ومن الواضح انه بالنسبه الى
مساله المناخ والصحه والتنميه كل هذه
المسائل يتعين علينا ان نحاول حلها مع
بعضنا البعض الامين العام واضحا ويرى
وضع في العالم على ما هو عليه ولديه مخاوف
وقلق ولكنه عازم على العمل على حلول دعونا
نتذكر عندما نتحدث عن الامم المتحده ما
الذي نتحدث عنه لان الامم المتحده طبعا
فيها الامين العام الذي لديه صوت ولكن ليس
لديه سلطه حقيقيه السلطه الحقيقيه في هذه
المنظمه تبقى في ايدي الدول الاعضاء وهذا
ما يجب ان يكون عليه الوضع وبالتالي يتعين
على الدول الاعضاء ان تت خطى الاختلافات
في وجهات النظر والانقسامات للمضيه قدما
هنا السؤال سيدي جريك الامم المتحده تولام
دائما وربما المشاهد العربي يطرح هذا
السؤال في ذهنه انه الامم الامم المتحده
تبدو متحمسه اكثر مثلا للوضع في اوكرانيا
وحرب روسيا على اوكرانيا بينما فيما يتعلق
بالقضيه الفلسطينيه لا يبدو ان هناك
اهتماما كبيرا في موضوع سوريا يعني يقترب
عدد المبعوتين الى 10 ربما ثمانيه او تسعه
مبعوتين اماميين هناك فشل في الملف الليبي
كيف تفسر ذلك
يمكنني ان اقول لك من وجهه نظري الامين
العامل المتحده هو يتعامل مع كل هذه
الاوضاع كمسائل ذات اولويه غالبا ما نتحدث
عن الوضع بين اسرائيل او في اسرائيل
وفلسطين اليوم روزماري مثلت الامين العام
في الاستماع الذي نظمه الاتحاد الاوروبي
والجامعه العربيه والسعوديه بتعمل من
الاردن ومصر لاعاده انخراط دولي للوصول
الى حل سياسي الوضع في الميدان في اسرائيل
وفلسطين هو هشه للغايه ويبعث الى القلق
نحن نرى ان الشعب الفلسطيني يستمر في
المعاناه وفي سوريا لدينا السيد وهو
المبعوث السياسي الذي يعمل باتجاه الحل
السياسي بتوكيد من المجلس مجلس الامن
وطبعا هناك عرقله سياسيه ولكن نحن لدينا
حضور في سوريا الامم المتحده تن- تقف الى
جانب الشعب السوري وتحاول ان تساعد الشعب
السوري للتخفيف من معاناه الشعب السوري
ولكن الاجابه لوضع حد لمعاناه الشعب في
سوريا في ليبيا في اي مكان في العالم هو
من خلال الحلول السياسيه ونحاول ان نعمل
على حشد الجهود السياسيه والقاده في كل
انحاء العالم يجب ان يضعوا مصلحه الشعوب
اولا عوضا على المصالح الشخصيه وهذه هي
الطريقه التي نتخطى من خلالها المشاكل
السياسيه
طيب هل يمكن تخطي اذا هذه المشاكل
يغيب عنها ربما قد الدول مهمه الصين ليست
موجوده روسيا ليست موجوده بريطانيا ليست
موجوده فرنسا ليست موجوده هل هذا يؤثر على
سير اعمال هذه الدوره سلبا
اعتقد ان النقطه الاساسيه هي ان مسؤوليه
البلدان لا تتلخص بحضور القاده على سبيل
المثال اجتماع مجلس الامن مقعد روسيا
والصين وفرنسا والمملكه المتحده سوف
املاؤه مسؤولون كبار البلدان تشارك القاده
لديهم اسباب لم تسمح لهم بالقدوم هناك
اولويات متعدده في الداخل في هذه البلدان
او مسائل اخرى اثرت على هذا القرار ولكن
نقطه الاساسيه هي ان هذه البلدان سوف تمثل
لن يكون هناك مقاعد فارغه في الجمعيات
العامه وما من مقاعد فارغه في مجلس الامن
شكرا جزيلا لك سيد ستيفان دو جاريك
المتحدث باسم الامينه العام للامم المتحده
شكرا لك
شكرا
وبهذا اذا تنتهي اذا نافذه الثانيه من
نيويورك نعود مره اخرى الى ليله في الدوحه
وبقيه الحصاد اليك ليلى
بالاجواء الماطره عندك في الواقع لم يبقى
لي شيء في الحصاد باستثناء هذا الخبر ربما
السعوديه الامير فيصل بن فرحان انه لن
يكون هناك حل للصراع الفلسطيني الاسرائيلي
بدون دوله فلسطينيه
واضافت تصريحات
[موسيقى]
مشكله تقنيه بسيطه بالميكروفون عذرا وصلنا
الى ختام الحصاد شكرا جزيلا لكم على
المتابعه
[موسيقى]